[Music]  told me that you recently got a tattoo  in an unusual area your lower lip yeah  yeah have you seen it no I haven't okay  we see that getting uncomfortable close  huh  the same hostility against your dentist  yeah what what is what what possessed  you to do that I mean what what state of  mind were you when you said yeah I'm  gonna get suck it on my lower on the  inner side of my I was super Zen and  [Laughter]  [Music]  really calm I get tattoos inside my face  yoga I know I was just kind of like fed  up with all like nasty little bloggers  and I was like you know what it's not  good yeah so you got that done if it  must really hurt to have it put on the  lower yeah that sucked I wouldn't I  wouldn't do that again